en este vídeo vamos a intentar obtener
el límite de esta expresión cuando
extiende a 3 y quiero que podamos
entender el significado de este límite
viendo qué valores toma esta expresión
cuando nos acercamos más y más a 3
primero quiero que pienses que es lo que
le pasa a esta expresión cuando x es
igual a 3 bueno obtendrían 3 elevado al
cubo menos 3 por 3 al cuadrado entre 5
por 3 menos 15 así que en x igual a 3
esta expresión toma el valor de m
veamos en el numerador me queda 27 27 en
lo cual es 0 y en el denominador me
queda 15 menos 15 que también es cero es
decir que esto es igual a 0 entre 0 por
lo tanto esta expresión no está definida
en x igual a 3
veamos si puedo entender el significado
de lo que vale este límite cuando x
tiende a 3 y para hacer esto voy a hacer
una tabla bueno de hecho voy a hacer dos
tablas en la primera aquí tengo a x ya
kim am x cúbico menos 3 x cuadrada entre
5 x menos 15 y déjame hacer otra
exactamente igual tengo por acá a x y
por acá a x kubica
menos 3 x cuadrada entre 5 x menos 15 no
es necesario que hagas dos tablas pero
la razón del por qué estoy haciendo dos
tablas es que esto lo hará mucho más
intuitivo pero podrías hacerlo todo en
una sola tabla lo que voy a hacer en
esta primera tabla es tomar valores más
y más cercanos a tres por la izquierda
es decir por valores menores que 3 por
ejemplo voy a fijarme en el 2.9 y vamos
a evaluar la expresión en 2.9 y también
haré lo mismo con el valor de x igual a
2.99 así que nos acercamos más a 3 e
incluso podemos acercarnos más a 3 y
probar con dos puntos 999 así que en
este caso estamos intentando encontrar
cuánto
de esta expresión cuando tomamos valores
cada vez más cercanos a tres por la
izquierda es decir este es el límite por
la izquierda el límite por la izquierda
y porque digo por la izquierda bueno si
lo pienso en el plano coordenada
estos valores están a la izquierda de
tres pero se están acercando más sin más
y más a tres nos estamos moviendo a la
derecha pero estos son los valores de x
que están a la izquierda de tres que son
menores que tres ahora para que existe
este límite tenemos que aproximarnos a
lo mismo por la derecha es decir debemos
aproximarnos a lo mismo por ambos lados
por la derecha y por la izquierda así
que vamos a hacer lo mismo y buscar el
límite por la derecha
el límite por la derecha y qué valores
tomaremos bueno vamos a tomar valores
mayores que 3 podríamos tomar 3.1 y
acercarnos más y evaluar en 3.01 y
acercarnos aún más a 3 y fijarnos en
3.001 y entre más y más nos acerquemos a
3 vamos a tener una mejor aproximación o
dicho otra manera vamos a tener un mejor
significado de a qué se aproxima este
límite y podríamos acercarnos más y no
sé evaluar esto en 2.900 99 9999 o en
3.000 0 0 0 0 1 o lo que sea ten cuidado
hay veces en que la gente habla del
límite por ambos lados o por la
izquierda y por la derecha y creo que el
límite por la izquierda es tomar valores
negativos y el de la derecha valores
positivos pero eso no siempre es cierto
como podemos ver aquí el límite por la
izquierda se refiere a evaluar la
expresión en valores por la izquierda
del valor x
al cual intentamos acercarnos ojo estos
no son valores negativos estamos
aproximándonos a tres por valores
menores que tres y aquí estamos
mayores que tres así que es momento de
calcular esta expresión voy a llenar
esta tabla y lo estoy haciendo muy
rápido para que no tengas que ver como
lleno y tecleo todos estos valores en la
calculadora
y ahora basándonos en lo que vemos aquí
puedo hacer la afirmación de que este
límite se aproxima a 1.8 se aproxima a
1.8 y como he dicho en el futuro vamos a
tener las herramientas para calcular
este límite de manera exacta pero si no
estuviera seguro de esto podrías tomar
valores aún más cercanos a 3 bueno
espero que todo esto te haya servido
para darte una idea de cómo obtener un
límite por medio de una tabla
continuaremos con más calma en el
siguiente vídeo saludos